the movie begins with a couple Nora and
Alec from Los Angeles driving to the
countryside for a getaway however on the
way to their destination they get lost
they stop at a Way Station to seek help
but there's no one inside Nora can't
even find a bathroom to relieve herself
and instead she discovers someone's cell
phone and purse despite the strange find
though she relieves herself in the open
without a care in the world unknown to
her there is a bloody skull of a human
nearby Nora then returns to the car and
casually talks about the belongings she
found at the weigh station however Alec
doesn't appear overly concerned because
he's more worried about the car running
low on fuel along the way the couple
comes across a woman whose car has
stopped working Alec offers to help by
jump starting her car and immediately
gets to work meanwhile the ladies start
chatting and the woman asks Nora if she
is married to Alec this comment makes
Nora feel very uncomfortable and she
firmly states that it's none of her
business unfortunately the woman gets
offended by this and starts criticizing
Rising the couple she even goes as far
as calling them irresponsible and stupid
meanwhile despite his sincere attempts
Alec is not able to fix the car guess he
is stupid this further annoys the woman
and she insults Alec by calling him a
lousy boyfriend enraged that they are
being chastised for no reason the couple
gets into their car and drives away
leaving the woman behind while driving
Nora expresses her disdain for the
countryside citing encounters with
people like the old woman is one of the
reasons after a while they find a
crowded Diner and stop over to have a
meal the waitress tells them the menu
and they order non-veg burgers and
drinks however when they try it they
find the taste strange Alex then notices
that a man is staring at Nora weirdly
this makes him uncomfortable and he
insists on leaving Nora also agrees and
they prepare to exit the diner without
finishing their meal however on their
way out the man abruptly stops them and
warns Nora that she is not safe in this
Village in the next scene Alec appears
to be genuinely worried about what the
man said that earlier but Nora believes
he is merely a local eccentric after a
while they stop at a gas station and
Alec refuels the car he also inquires
with the cashier named Andrew about
nearby lodging options and the latter
directs them to some rental cabins
further up the road continuing their
Journey they come across a dilapidated
cabin initially Nora is unsettled by The
Rundown place but with no options left
they decide to enter as they climb the
stairs together they are startled by the
presence of the landlord whose face is
twisted and distorted he greets them
warmly and asks if they are in need of a
room when Alec confirms that they are
looking for a place to stay the landlord
leads them to a nearby cabin and reveals
that it used to be rented by Scouts and
campers after he leaves an anxious Nora
can fly than Alec expressing her
suspicions about the landlord however he
calms her down assuring her that
everything is fine as the two talk the
camera pans to the top of the adjacent
bunk bed which appears to be Blood
Stained during the night a person
wearing a sheep mask is seen hiding
under the couple's bed he slowly emerges
from under the bed and looms over them
threateningly he said he said the next
morning Nora wakes up to find herself
confined in a dog cage the ghastly sight
almost gives her a heart attack she
attempts to free herself while calling
out for Alec but he is nowhere to be
found a man with a goat mask then
appears and thumps her cage indicating
that she should remain quiet scared Nora
obliges but after the masked man leaves
she tries to escape she notices a rock
outside her cage and manages to grab it
through the bars she then tries to use
it to smash the lock of her cage but
just then the goat masked man returns
along with another man wearing a cow
mask the latter approaches her slowly
and sedates her moo he says later on
Nora regains Consciousness in a barn
strapped to its chair with her legs
forcibly parted a rabbit man then
appears and artificially inseminates her
with a God every we're doing too many of
these with a large syringe-like tool
leaving her screaming in pain next Nora
is placed in her cage and taken
somewhere by the two men from earlier on
the way she notices other other masked
people in the barn doing their daily
chores she also sees a man cutting up a
man's corpse it becomes apparent that in
this Farm human meat is produced after a
while the two men ultimately dropped
Nora in the barn the scene then cuts to
a room where Alec and other men have
been confined in a cage as he regains
Consciousness he learns that he has been
tightly gagged and stripped of his
clothes Alex tries to talk to the other
men in the barn but without success a
group of the villagers that appears and
one by one they bash the heads of the
captive men to knock them out soon the
villagers turned to Alec in what turns
out to be a scary scene
he tries to escape but the bad guys
eventually knock him out next an
unconscious Alec is loaded onto a
trolley and taken to the slaughterhouse
for further processing the scene then
reveals that the compound is actually a
communal farm and it is run by
individuals in animal masks they capture
men and butcher them for meat while
women are reared for their milk the
harvested meat is subsequently utilized
to provide catering services for
weddings and various ceremonies
shockingly it is revealed that the
landlord from earlier is the leader of
this disturbing organization an apt
metaphor for the way that we treat
animals however the director of this
movie still has some problems to work
out in the next scene the landlord is
seen receiving a huge order that
requires a large quantity of meat
however a worker informs him that they
don't have enough men to meet the demand
with no options the landlord decides to
use one of the women who's confined for
milk production he then proceeds to the
dairy barn where numerous cages hold
lactating women the landlord assesses
their milk production rates to choose
the lease productive woman for Slaughter
during the inspection he notices that a
woman has been covertly breastfeeding
her baby this anger is the landlord as
he has been struggling to meet the
demand of milk and meat for his business
on his orders a worker then seizes her
baby and I'm just not going to read this
part after the two heartless men leave
the woman is inconsolable and she cries
for her child it's then revealed that
Andrew from earlier in the movie works
for the landlord and his work is to
direct the visitors to The Cabins
however Andrew is mentally disabled and
he talks to the distressed woman in a
patronizing way this infuriates her and
she calls him sick in turn Andrew also
gets angry and calls her a bad human get
wrecked later on when a worker comes to
the dairy barn to investigate he
discovers the woman dead it's clear that
Andrew killed the woman and ran away
from there when the landlord learns of
this he angrily orders his men to locate
Andrew why the hell would we the viewer
care about what happens to Andrew inside
the barn Nora discovers another captive
who is situated next to her in a stable
the woman is connected to a milking
machine and is being continuously milked
when Nora inquires about what is
happening at the farm the woman says
it's best if you don't know because
there is no way to escape she then
discloses that she has been held at the
farm for the purpose of breeding for the
past two years she has been bred
repeatedly to the point where she can no
longer conceive as the two continued
chatting we hear the cries of another
woman named Ashley who has also been
held captive for three years Nora tries
to offer support to her assuring her
that they will find a way to escape
however Ashley asserts that escape is
impossible in this location as the
masked man always manage to find them in
the slaughterhouse a masked man catches
Andrew playing with a pair of
decapitated heads as Andrew do the
lunatic pleads that he is not to blame
but he has forcefully taken away the
landlord then reprimands Andrew for
neglecting his duties and explicitly
instructs him to not play with his food
in this case he refers to humans as the
food right after this Andrew is assigned
to a masked supervisor who directs him
to feed the imprisoned men their meats I
mean meals however while performing this
task Andrew accidentally tips over the
food pots spilling all of its contents
fearing punishment he flees and the
masked worker chases after him they
eventually end up inside the greenhouse
but Andrew seizes a handful of oregano
and continues his Escape he rushes to
the landlord in the kitchen presenting
the oregano as an offering you can
pretend it's pot and sell it to stupid
teenagers trust me during a tidy profit
strangely enough the landlord accepts
the gift and pardons Andrew when the
worker who had been chasing after Andrew
arrives he receives orders from the
landlord to dispose of the unproductive
women that are unable to produce milk
the scene then cuts to the barn where
Nora watches the woman from earlier
being processed and turned into meat
after The Butchers leave she breaks down
in despair however she is seen
interrupted by a noise at her door to
her surprise Alec is still alive and
conscious Nora gasps in excitement and
after a bit of struggle they somehow
managed to escape the Stables however
the danger is not over yet as they still
have to make their way across the prop
property while avoiding the masked man
Nora assists Alec in getting to a truck
for their getaway but it fails to start
at a critical moment forcing them to
continue on foot eventually they come
across a church where they take a break
as the couple looks around they notice
that the faces of Jesus and his
followers have been replaced with animal
masks just then a man and a cow mask
enters the church he starts praying dear
cow Jesus please grant me my cow wish
and the couple takes this as the perfect
opportunity to flee Unfortunately they
are caught and the cow man rings a bell
alerting the other workers at the farm
while running Alec becomes trapped in a
bear trap and Nora tries to free him
however upon seeing the masked workers
approaching Alec tells her to run Nora
doesn't want to leave the love of her
life behind but she has no other choice
as she reluctantly runs away the workers
catch up to Alec and crush his head with
a rock meanwhile Nora takes refuge in
the male Barn there one of the male
captives notices her presence and
silently signals her to flee for her own
safety Nora swiftly approaches his cage
and asks him to help her Escape From The
Wretched farm with some hesitation the
man tells her about a bus that the
workers utilize to transport their
victims he also tells her where the
workers keep the keys with this
information Nora heads to the spacious
area where numerous cars are parked
there she spots a masked driver
fortunately with his back turned to her
taking advantage of this Norris strikes
him in the head with a hammer and knocks
him out right then three masked
individuals spot Nora and run towards
her but she gets in the car and drives
through the fence unfortunately she soon
runs out of gas and is forced to exit
the car she is then chased across the
property and with no options left Nora
ultimately returns to the Stables there
she frees Ashley and helps her outside
they then make their way to the bus but
learn that the keys are missing although
disappointed Morrow remembers what the
Caged man had told her earlier so she
goes to the specified house to retrieve
the keys she manages to find them and
then returns to the bus for some reason
Ashley appears very worried and when
Nora starts the bus she realizes that
all the seats have been occupied by
masked people much to her Horror the
movie ends with the masked workers
gathered around a table where Nora and
Ashley have been served like roast
piggies with apples in their mouths
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching